This equation is a linear equation.
Linear equations have
the following properties.
Linear equations must
have an equal sign.
So here we have an equal sign.
Linear equations must have an expression
on both sides of the equal sign.
And we see here that we have expressions
And no variables will have
an exponent greater than 1.
And x here doesn't have
Previously, we talked about
algebraic expressions.
Algebraic expressions do
not have an equal sign.
You could only find a value for
an algebraic expression if you were
given values to substitute in for
the variables.
This is called evaluating an expression.
Notice that value is in
the word evaluating.
This is different from an equation,
which has an equal sign.
When you see an equal sign, you know
you can solve the linear equation to
find the value for the variable.
Please indicate if each of these
is an expression or an equation.